if I'm not mistaken you flew in from New
York this morning
Toronto oh this is bad yeah
why couldn't you fly it are you filming
something yesterday yes filming
something till 5:00 in the morning in
Toronto and then I got in a plane so I'm
like I'm sorry if I'm weird that's
impressive
I give you all the credit in the world
for pulling this off thank you seriously
yeah okay I'm out that's all I have
that's unbelievable but so what is it
like you're what it's like not being the
youngest person on set so weird cuz
that's like the only experiences that
I've had um very interesting [ __ ] like
I'm not as a Dulles sometimes I think
that I am like I'm still a kid at heart
um and it honestly was just reminded me
of when I was younger and I used to not
be a self-conscious these kids were just
so free and with these kind of movies
you know it's a lot of alts and they'd
be like try this and they just try it
and I would throw one at me and I had to
go oh wait how am I gonna say this and
they just try it so that was really like
inspiring to go back to that part of me
yeah like pure imagination chuckling
yeah um I was first of all the movie
made me laugh a ridiculous amount so
okay so let me start with that but I was
really surprised at its really adult
yeah and it's and they're really young
so what was it like reading the script
for the first time or you like they're
never gonna make this this is like
there's some inappropriate stuff in
those yeah no I definitely it's a it is
an inappropriate film for children um
but I also feel like my friend's sibling
I just think if anyone has access to
finding these things out now and some
movie is gonna was going to find comedy
in that because I just think I even knew
I asked so many questions I think around
nine and ten what does this mean like
what is this buh-buh-buh-buh and I think
the more that my parents didn't tell me
the more I would want to go search it
out like I want the world to be a little
bit more open about section and maybe
not like sex dolls but sexuality because
I think it's crazy to me that you can
show like so much gun violence and so
many movies were not like it's so adult
there was a child
but we're just talking about like sex
and it's a different thing listen it's a
complete [ __ ] double standard yeah I
I have such issues with the MPAA you
shouldn't say anything I can
I think the MPA is full of [ __ ] I don't
mean to say that on camera but it's
[ __ ] it's straight-up but I I
appreciate that this film what it's
trying to do yeah was there ever a
moment though we're like the three of
them were like trying to get information
out of you instead of like their parents
do you know what I mean definitely I
think I'm like yeah I'm like the young
lady friend and I would just say I don't
know I have absolutely no idea what that
means I hope one day I'll figure it out
- yeah right exactly
yo just but they seem so sweet though
there's such good god that's what was
the best part of it I think I would have
come away from it feeling differently if
I didn't feel like there were such good
guys and that yeah everything was just
handled very delicately nothing they
weren't just given props and and it
wasn't talked at like they it was just
handle in a very good way and that's
what made me feel good about it
completely um is there a day or two that
you will always remember from filming
this thing honestly we we shot this I
don't even remember where it is in the
movie but we're really meeting in a
parking lot sure the truck with the
drone and Keith just did this improv for
like 25 minutes about saying how mad he
was that we made him walk all the way
through the parking lot cuz he was so
tired and it didn't make it in the movie
but gene sent it to me so I have it on
my phone and it's so funny and I just
think he's gonna have like the biggest
career and so I was just so excited to
like have him scream at me for 20
minutes yeah that's amazing actually and
I totally want to say it yeah I'm that
no to have to stop I just want to say
thanks for flying in and congrats on
being part of the movie